ed you know what channel that's on right
the big eight channel eight and there's
something christian and all of you don't
realize the biggest shamar fan alive is
denise valdez
i am not kidding
she watches it and you can't even talk
to her because she's salivating the
whole time all right look outside from
tower camp looking at the las vegas trip
it's gonna be a nice night tonight for
all you're gonna be out about of course
the bts army out tonight look at that
four degrees warmer than yesterday the
humidity seven percent that's it that's
how dry it is out there and that will
continue for tomorrow too 86 right now
teddy hills 83 for summerlin 90 downtown
we're 90 even for sunrise manor green
valley st for you roads ranch 85-91
southern highlands so warmer today than
tomorrow i'm going to keep that trend
going for tomorrow too 85 for indian
springs 97 for death valley 86 boulder
city and 93 currently for you down river
in lofland we've got a brief weak system
just to the north right now providing
some showers in the pacific northwest
we're getting some high clouds passing
through from that one but the bigger one
is going to come in from british
columbia you can see it dive down here
in our future cast we'll start to see it
by sunday pick up the winds a little
more but by monday that's when it really
impacts us in the form of strong winds
remember that high wind watch we're also
going to see a huge temperature drop by
the time we get to tuesday once this
passes through and i those very slight
chances for showers too so here's your
weekend forecast coming very close to
that record high of 95 for saturday and
then the numbers drop a lot on sunday
and monday look at this high 70s
the wind watch though is issued for
monday remember at 11 a.m but the
strongest winds are going to be monday
and tuesday as you can see here on our
wind forecast we'll see them between 40
to 50 on monday and then in the 40s to
maybe mid 40s for tuesday we could see
some sporadic algae there's a
possibility some blowing dust as well
with those strong winds 64 degrees
though for tonight that's your overnight
low
very nice and mild night tonight very
light winds tomorrow 92 degrees near
record temperatures expected for
tomorrow like we said but it will become
breezy later on in a day your highs for
tomorrow look at this in the low 90s
across the valley
sunblock tomorrow for sure 88 summerlin
spring valley 91 94 green valley same
for sunrise manor 91 aliante 91
mountains edge remember we should be at
77 degrees this time of year this is how
warm it's going to be for tomorrow and
that's why we'll come very close to that
record high for tomorrow 102 death
valley tomorrow 101 for you in laughlin
90 for boulder city here is your eight
day forecast now like we talked about
the weekend will cool off on sunday the
stronger winds come monday very slight
shower chances on tuesday look at that
temperature drop 62 degrees but your
morning lows
in the mid to high 40s that's
temperatures we get in the winter guys
and we're going to see that this week
and then later on the week looks a whole
lot more like chilmar moore
temperatures in the high 70s back over
to you silky and beautiful